[Musique]
côté météo pi2g nagui abu jamal il est
très méfiant et tout voir tout qui est
arrivé ce que je suis et j'y trouve au
moitié m'a dit le plus beau grain gars
du monde quoi quelques n'est pas de cet
avis titus est ce que je suis beau têtu
ce ne te gêne pas lundi moi la vérité
comme un mets trouves-tu et vous mordez
reste un grand gala est bien debout de
trop haut pour un affreux tu as dit
affreux et j'ai envoyé quatre premiers
et ceci cela a sapé le fermer le 17 sept
encadrent cette image si maintenant il
est râpeux votre grand gâteau apple gens
m'envoient ray en perspective il faut
que l'on sorte de cette cave on va
envoyer une lettre à melchior métro
melchior wathelet cave venaient à mon
secours fini tous voilà une lettre qui
va me sauver
faty rapporterait plaindra melchior
hippie qui doit bien compris cette
lettre et pour marca ici le moral mail
qui en ramenant partir de là titus me
fait beaucoup de peine
aujourd'hui les punis et lâche
c'est regrettable lens ce blanc trust ou
qu'est-ce que si une lettre
beneteau de la moitié si une lettre à
lire c'est bien petit grain de mousse
15e la lire la voix d'un cran kaka nous
allons lire la lettre et voyant et jeux
par exemple
alors moi ce que tu sais lire mon nom je
n'ai pas grandi à gaza n'est pas pêché
c'est illisible fait seul melchior
pour alain des chiffres un mail en mail
tiens tu vas me dire si tous les postes
donnez-lui mosca cherves être un renard
j'en suis très flatté choyée par le
temps c'est une lettre de titus qui vous
appelle à son secours en jeu comprend un
matelas dans mon bac je veux la
transforma je voulais confie alors mal
sur cette liste il dit doivent nous
allons le savoir
à quimper accueille bla et voilà lycée
je vous prie en soignant à votre diction
shaykh gros achats merci de m'avoir fait
offert mais dans ma cage et c'est bien
tu es et c'est très bien
je suis très heureux je m'abuse importe
où et d'un ciré race trait le plus
longtemps possible
c'est bien ce truc ou à ces titus qui a
écrit ça il s'amuse des saccages amène
aux minots me nominer
mais je ne fais pas et je ne veux pas
manquer on ne vient pas mon taux courts
pour vous que sa fille lui est bien
remis ma lettre tous tellement mal dans
ce cadre têtu c'est puni je ne vais pas
qu'il se blesse dans ses cages
je vais là lui confisquer aller ceci
vient avec moi voilà but monde chez moi
qui commande ici
cela s'est si oui laquelle titus à
l'échangé qui ont bouffé vous l'offrir
api blé importé lac à ce jeu-là
confisqué haha tu vois la biesme
punitive tu sais tu es privé de cages et
je suis bien content des copains vous ne
comprend rien et vous il est dans
d'heureuses bonhomme avoue that là et on
veut vous allez m'expliquer ce qui se
passait
oui si la lettre que bell qui aura lieu
au cra riac je reçois omar amis ma
famille quand très bon la liberté
et après en fait est une autre histoire
[Musique]